thank you very much Academy for this  great honor the reason that I made this  short film Durga  it'd be called a sin days of this Leto  that later Chinese village go has been  ignited about this better society and  the sorrow of her family had also be  overlooked by all I want to tell those  over that overlooked and untold stories  and bring those amazing in the unique  characters into the light from like  through the power of the cinema so I  want to thank and while you New York  University is New York University teach  me how to tell story by filmmaking thank  you everyone  in my cousin accrue without every day  without the effort of your era to hurt  working that freezing cold winter this  film cannot be made and the story cannot  be told and thank you from a family and  friends without your love and support I  would able to be on this stage at this  moment thank you everyone  what a wonderful night thank you